all right you ready we're gonna do this
can you wave to the nice people
awesome anyone out there you really
really like
oh all right i guess jeff is going to be
the person he likes the most
um this is hexy hex he's going to be
here and help me through
this presentation uh
enough fun with hexy democratizing
hardware is the name of this talk
i am your guide to this
and to be ultra hipster in this domain
i'm using powerpoint
that may prove to be a bad decision
as a life choice
but hey let's go with it uh because if
i'm gonna do something i should do it
all out so
who am i why do why am i standing up
here why do i add any value to your day
hopefully i do add value that's sort of
the target
um i'm chris williams you probably know
me as
voodoo tiki god if you know me not too
many people actually even know my name
is chris williams they mostly know me as
voodoo tiki god
i run js conf robots conf capital js
helps set up node conf as well as a
plethora of other things
i'm the instigator of the node bots
node copter node boats and node rockets
yes i said boats we take geeks we put
them with electronics and put them in
the water
what could go wrong and i do all that
because i
am the author of node serial port which
for most of you if you've never heard of
the serial port you're like well that's
cool that died like three decades ago
why
why is this even a thing but the s in
usb
to many people's uh knowledge is for
serial
it's for serial port access the
universal serial bus
so it's still very much alive today and
that's actually the gateway between
the magical world of computers and the
magical world of
robots and that gateway is a very
powerful thing
also less important to this discussion
i'm the creator of brjs
i also did the js logo that's been on
colbert report that is in fact the top
point of my life
everything since then has been not even
close
and i'm also the founder and cto of a
company called emerging technology
advisors
where we take a lot of stuff that i'm
about to show you and we help
large companies large organizations
embrace them and figure out how to bring
them into their life
uh so as part of that it's good to
describe what my quest is i am
on a quest to change this world my
general goal is to take the hard out of
hardware
to make the complex things in life
simple it's a
pretty simple task right no no hard
things there
i want to make hardware available and
accessible to anyone
right now there is a bit of a barrier if
i were to ask you what would happen if
you licked a 9 volt battery
how many of you and you don't have to
actually raise your hands but
would raise your hand think that it
might erupt you in flames
i mean it's a thing it happens a
surprising amount of software developers
have been
abstracted away from this wonderful
world of hardware and because of that
they are fearful truly fearful
of accessing it that they may blow up
something that they may burn an led out
that costs
less than a penny that they may erupt
themselves into flames
and the likelihood of that i mean there
is a likelihood of that but it's not a
huge likelihood
and my goal with this is that if i can
bring like prometheus if i can bring
fire to the world and let the world have
it then they will set themselves
on fire no that's not the goal um they
will be able to make fire for themselves
cook meals
and go forward so that is my hope is the
awaiting of the coming of the robot
overlords
and ideally by democratizing access to
the hardware and democratizing the
knowledge of hardware
i will be able to allow many many more
people to join in
on the hardware discussion
so in short i'm basically trying to make
robotics as simple as programming a web
page
that's the long and short of this
presentation
that's it thank you bye the
the thing with this is that if i make it
as easy as a programming a web page
i have to make it in something that
would be similar to programming a web
page
and for better or for worse and i know
there's a general
agreement or disagreement depending upon
which side of the aisle you sit the
javascript is either the
best or worst programming language ever
to be created
and should either be used everywhere or
die in a fire
respectively i think yes i i said that
correctly
so uh for all intents and purposes uh
node.js was sort of the starting point
there's a lot of natural overlaps that
we'll go into
but i didn't want anyone here to think
that i'm saying node.js is the way the
path the light for this because
it's not it's just a piece of it and so
that's why i left
the tube blank there for you to fill in
whatever you want however you want it's
uh you know
that javascript for better for worse
has natural overlaps between the
hardware world it's an invented model
is a core part of it both in node and
also in browser-based programming
and that very much maps to the hardware
interrupt style
of straight hardware componentry
not to say that other models don't work
but this just has a natural overlap
you also have the benefit that objects
in a double op
world are supposed to render actual
objects but hey in the hardware world
they can actually render real
objects so i can have a servo object and
i can have it talk to a
another servo object and i can have it
talk to a board and ports and gpio
dropouts
gpio for those of you who don't know i
may use that a couple times
general purpose input output it allows
you to convert that to different signal
stanks
let's not go too far into it hardware by
nature up until last couple years is
mainly speaking
single threaded most of the chipsets
you'll buy in an arduino or
or other boards are single threaded
there is only one processor
there isn't hyper threading there isn't
anything glorious to that effect like
you have in a normal computer
it's single-threaded and so there's a
natural overlap with javascript which
still works in like the 1980s world
and is not process concurrent and
doesn't have threads
so there's actually well that's bad
normally this is actually a perfect
world where they work well together and
in both worlds blocking is a bad
thing so that's why there's also that
natural overlap
most important to this discussion about
democratizing hardware is the javascript
can
allow anyone to write code almost
anywhere now i'm not putting any
qualification on that code
it probably will be bad but it doesn't
matter it creates
change in the real world it causes
something
to move to shift to change
and this gave rise to a thing uh
lovingly termed nodebots
which was sort of the rise of this js
robotics ideology
and that has been about three years in
the making and it's
gone to the point where we have an
international nodebots day where there
are small groups
all around the world that get together
bring out different pieces of hardware
completely different projects
people who have never touched computers
are able to sit down
work build a robot control it and do
amazing things
and part of that genesis and part of
that start point was a thing called node
copter which you've probably seen if
you've ever seen like the demonstrations
of quadcopters which
unfortunately i was going to show you a
demonstration of it today but
uh thank you tsa we're not going to be
able to do that
um you're able to control a quadcopter
using just very simple
javascript programming take off land
sort of attributes and and functional
capabilities
that gave rise to a thing called johnny
5
which is done by rick waldron as the
curator and organizer of it
johnny 5 is a library that abstracts and
implements the ideas that i sort of put
forward in the
nodebots idea let's make rendering a
robot
like hexy here very similar to the
comprehensions of a document object
model or the dom
so just as we can render the dom in a
tree form of dependencies
we can similarly render that here this
is connected to that
that shin is connected to that leg that
leg is connected to that foot
and those then create an object model
that then we can now work with
and it's a very powerful thing to say
hey look here's this thing
go program it and up
as just anecdotal evidence we've been
able to work with five-year-olds to
75 year olds and allow them to access
programming and access robotics
through this method so it's an extremely
powerful thing
one of the other things that it provides
is since it's node
you do have access to a replied robotics
and bringing the power of a rebel the
ability to change things in real time
as a you know derivative of the ability
of changing code
allows people to make change
understand that if i press this key if i
do these keystrokes these commands
it's going to cause these change and
actually execute that in real time
and so what i'm going to do here is if
this all works out
where did that go i'm going to enter
this into the repple i already have the
stream open
with hexy that's what you saw earlier um
but
this code set is a great example and yes
it is callback hell but that's just part
of
node you source in the library
you tell hexy to zero which says hey i
want you to get
all your servos at the zero point and
then you tell hexy to get up
and then you tell hexy to dance so i'm
going to enter those in
since we already have the serial port
open here so
i'm going to tell hexy to go to zero
all right so this is the zero position
hexy is now has
all of hexy's servos at its zero point
and then we will go in and
copy
this
all right hexy get up
and all it's doing is it's just sending
the command and it all the magic happens
between
the host system and hexy it's just
sending commands across the serial port
to execute this
and as you can see this is very powerful
it reads similar to english and so now i
can do
the last one which everyone's waiting
for right everyone wants to see hexy
dance
all right we're going to make hexy dance
and there hexy's now dancing so this
shows you
a huge amount of power zero is actually
telling all of the servos here at the
same time
to go to the zero point and get up is
telling all of the servos
to control themselves such that you put
the legs out drop them and push them up
and then dance is obviously telling hexy
to dance
it's a very powerful thing that wraps up
and allows people to
very quickly see change do and
bringing that rebel power to developers
for
communicating to hardware is a hugely
powerful
and uh liberating sort of workflow
coincident to this and mainly from the
other side of it you have the open
source hardware movement i
would hope that everyone in this room
has heard of the maker movement if not
you owe it to yourself to get involved
as part of it
the maker movement does for hardware
what
uh sort of source forge early on and
github has done for software in terms of
let's share ideas in digital form back
and forth
and the maker movement does that
similarly of let's share digital designs
back and forth between each other and we
can use different manufacturers
different chip layouts different small
batch assembly
to create them locally and by sharing
that knowledge we help the whole world
and this one of the penultimate
beautiful pieces out of the maker
movement is the arduino this is an
arduino uno this is actually the
original heart and soul
of the node bots everything was built on
the architecture
of the arduino and what it does is it
allows that to basically become a
if you want to think about it like a rpc
handler do this
do that activate this pin do this change
this mutate this state
and drives it from the host machine
running javascript and so that way the
hardware does what the hardware does
best
and the computer does what the computer
does best
that's great but you have the thing that
we have here where hexy has a tail
and can only go so far due to
physics and that doesn't work out well
but the future is bigger it's brighter
it's already changing right in front of
us
you have wonderful things like this
spark board which is a arduino
compatible
wi-fi based chipset and what we've done
is we've used an adapter model
to allow the replacement of any of those
boards the arduino board with the
spark board with the beaglebone with the
pinocchio with the
tesla with the imp swap them out at the
under layer
and keep that top layer of code that
the developer the person coming on the
child
is able to just learn one code
instruction and have it work on multiple
platforms
said differently we've been able to
democratize access to all of these
devices
through one common interface that being
javascript which is accessible to all
which is a pretty cool thing um and that
brings wireless and all
i didn't know that had sound um and
coincident with this you have the
ability to gain access to
3d printers cnc laser cutters
basically this is a derivative out of
the maker movement where there are maker
shops there are
maker spaces that are set up all around
the united states all around the world
where any of you can walk in get access
to a 3d printer
print out whatever you want and walk out
that's all you have to do you don't even
have to pay for most of them
if you end up signing up you can it sort
of becomes like a gym membership
but you have access to all these great
technologies that are available
pretty much free to access and now that
sounds great for you all but it sounds
even more amazing in my mind
for pre-k up through post-secondary
children
who are wanting to change the world they
want to get out there they want to do
these things
and this affords them the ability to do
local manufacture to actually build
things they can touch
they can do and this comes into
a combination that provides accessible
robots hexy here is actually not
just a johnny 5 driven robot its pieces
are all done through a cnc
laser cut on plexiglass everything in
here
except for like the wires and the servos
is plexiglas that was cut
based off of open hardware designs so i
didn't make the
hardware designs i just downloaded them
and hit a button
to get a laser cutter to laser cut it
for me
that's a hugely powerful world now not
only do we have access to
software readily available but hardware
and that is transformative and we're
just now starting to
crack into what that world looks like
and for me i want to make sure that
access
is available to everybody so a couple
projects that we've been working on one
is pavelbot
named after a gentleman named pavel i'm
not even going to attempt his last name
but i'm something close to sigmatovich
i think i got it right i go with povel
that's why we didn't go with the sigma
tovic bot
uh we went with pavelbot it's a 35 35
total cost investment to do the wood
cutting
the board and on there is a spark wi-fi
chip set
35 dollars for that whole thing
delivered to you good to go you have a
robot
at that point that you can control via
rebel
even more exciting is something similar
to this which is a drone
quadcopter this one doesn't work right
now because the battery is is
uh the battery broke on the way over
um the quadcopters have four
hence the quad rotors that are
propellers that rotate and create
downward draft and can be manipulated to
be very agile and moving
this is a thing called the flexbot which
started out as a kickstarter for an open
source
design for a quadcopter the flexbot is
actually designed to be 3d printed
so that you could actually print your
own quadcopter
if you want to go buy it it's only fifty
dollars
which is not too bad the one over here
is a parrot it's a hundred dollars
both in very much the accessible range
to many people
and if you don't have fifty dollars but
want to get this
you can go to a makerspace and say hey
can i print this design
and you get it for zero dollars a little
bit of time investment
versus money investment now on the
opposite end of the spectrum
this robotics and open robotics idea has
blossomed a whole new realm of
uh next generation robotics or larger
order robotics
this is an open rov it actually runs a
bigle bone black
inside of it as well as running node.js
as well as running node serial port in
order to control the entire
rov system robotic oceanographic vehicle
this goes into the ocean or into caverns
and takes video streams and
sends the hd video back up through wi-fi
or through a direct channel
depending on how it's programmed it can
control itself in water
completely autonomously or with guided
controls
it lasts for about an hour in water it's
fantastic but the cool thing is is that
you don't have to know crazy deep sea
in all right that was a weird word
choice
crazy deep programming language c to
travel this in
the ocean or sea um you can just program
it entirely with javascript
and you can do it in a reply so you can
make immediate changes versus
slapping a firmware down into it and
it's locked and stuck
but why why chris why are you taking me
on this journey
um and why why are you doing this
mission what is the reasoning for this
quest
that's a great question and i wanted to
show you all the exciting things first
if you don't mind i'm going to let
hexy go to sleep just so that way the
servos don't burn out
there we go we can play with hexy later
um why why are we doing this so let's
peer into the future
let's let's try to figure out where the
next
let's go with five years what does the
next five years for the world look like
and that may help you understand so i'm
not telling anyone anything crazy
when i say the population is growing at
a rate that is almost
and arguably already out of control and
that will continue to go
this is a chart based off of the u.s
census bureau of where the world's going
to be
such that by 2020 we're already about 7
billion people on this earth
when we get to that level having all
seven billion people working to
feed care and to take uh
comfort of all other seven billion of
them
is almost impossible we will have to
have automation we will have to have
robotics and you're seeing this already
as
as agriculture moves over to robotics as
shipping and logistics moves over to
robotics and drone operations and
autonomy
we will need something we will need our
tools our technology in order to support
it
if we continue down the path where we
are right now where it's held by a tight
group of very very smart people then we
are stuck
because if those people pass on or more
importantly
move forward into the retirement or
older
stages of life their knowledge
disappears with them
and that is a fundamental problem this
is the aging population base
u.s will hit the baby boomers leaving
the market leaving the knowledge
work area in 2020 so in
five years six to five years we look at
most of the existing domain tacit
knowledge leaving
the domain entirely without any great
replacement due to what we've done with
our generations and if you look at it
the generational shift here you notice
that your gen xers stay constant all the
way through
the bottom is right now the top is the
future you have your millennials taking
over
in five years we will see a massive
shift in the workforce
where domain knowledge disappears
completely
and that's a problem and unless we make
access to this um this is a quote from
intel labs
that the trends are already indicating
that growing numbers of jobs will
require significantly more complex
interdisciplinary skills
such as problem solving judgment
listening data analysis relationship
building
collaborating and communicating with
multinational co-workers in short
we need a lot more people who do
everything
that's the long and the short of this
right now we're not arming and equipping
our fellow
uh humans with that capability
and so unfortunately we're creating a
narrower and narrower pipeline
that does not support the infrastructure
that we need as a society
and it's my belief that we need to
democratize and you may have different
opinion and that's that's fantastic we
should discuss it
um we need to democratize access to that
knowledge
we need to democratize access to the
parts
and that's where the open source
hardware movement comes in that anyone
can gain access
and build their own robot and i
encourage you go build your own robot
but don't just do it in isolation
find a three-year-old and build it with
them find a ten-year-old and build it
with them
that you will change not just your life
and their life by building this you will
change
society along the way the more people we
give this to
and we make it easy for them to jump
onto we make it easy for them to gain
access to to control
to build their own emerging ideas the
more people we do that
with the greater societal change we have
and it's because of that that i'm
working towards a modern education
platform
through the use of drones and at this
point i would show you that but like i
said the battery's dead so
imagine this drone flying around as i'm
talking um
in the modern most of us
had some sort of access to the first
entrance of programming
some subset of us had access to that by
way of uh
logo which was that turtle thing that
you made move one space and you would
see
the thing on the green screen which was
horrible move one space and turn left
and remove that
for most people that's sort of an entry
point because i can see i can change
i can execute i can understand the
causation of my change
this is that modern platform i can lift
off hey it lifted off
it would if it was working hey turn left
and it would turn left
hey go up and it would go up kids get
this
without any problem there is no
complexity to this
i did that it moved yay and then they
start building
further and further up to the point
where in
about a day you can have somebody even
us
developers can in eight hours go from no
knowledge about a programming
programming a drone to creating open cv
based
facial recognition and tracking drones
that can fly and charge at people
and that's only eight hours for
developers i mean
it took uh government organizations
millions of dollars to make that happen
we do it in eight hours
kids can do it in about three and they
are much better at this than we are
because they don't come to it with their
preconceived notions their minds are
clear
they create wonderful things and it's
for this that i believe we have an
opportunity to combine
the arts sort of the logic and the
creativity
to combine the art and the science of
programming
and through those we can create a much
more perfect human
and a much more perfect human society
not
focusing on one to the to the
declination of the other but to work on
both
as a happy medium now you might say
chris how do you do that
with this this is all technology it is
but it also is not
much the same way that we use hexi here
to demonstrate
that we can do modern fabrication the
artistic quality of
i want to make this round or i want to
make this square i want to make it have
horns on the back i want to do this the
ability to take a
person set them in front of a cad
program that are very accessible
nowadays
and say create your own thing create
your own monster
allow them to do that hit a button print
it out in plastic
in a 3d form and generate a robot is
incredibly powerful
allows them the freedom of creativity to
create whatever they want
cast it into the real world and control
it
that's tremendously powerful
if we want to look even further than
just five years out there's also another
reason why we're doing this
programmable matter if you don't know
what programmable matter is or have not
yet heard of it
you should program as you look at the
atomic structures of elements
there's ability to create and isolate
electrons that
can present like their own atom brand
new atoms as it were
that you can control with electrical
flow
much like we control computers with
electrical
flow through semiconductors imagine a
semiconductor in just the same way that
we do with computers where you change
memory on
off and gates and stuff of that nature
but with actual matter so that chair
right there if i applied some degree of
electricity to it
i can turn it into a car or that
projector i can turn it blue
by just changing the electrical
compounds inherent in it
that world is a drastically different
world and that world
is sitting right at the threshold of
today
and if we don't democratize access to
that
i fear that world if we can take that
world no
it's stopped let me see if i can get it
going for you again yeah there we go
if we don't allow everybody
equally to access that then i'm not sure
i want to be around
there is power in this there is huge
amount of power to allow anyone to
create anything and mutate it
based off of charges that in a small
subset of hands is dangerous
that in everybody's hands is tremendous
and so i leave you with this note that
the future is right now
it is time to start doing what we all
thought was science fiction before you
entered into this room
today and most importantly it's today
that you need to go back and teach
pre-k through post-secondary school kids
these things it doesn't take you more
than an hour
really to go and say hey look i just
bought a cool
drone for 50 bucks yay let's go
play with it and everyone in the
neighborhood everyone at a school will
be giddy as can be the principal will be
blown away
do call them before you show up with one
of these though
schools are a little bit touchy about
that for good reason
so um but do please go back out into
your own communities take
the knowledge that we have here the the
incredible smarts we have gathered in
this room
give it back out to the world give it
back out to the the next generation
because they're going to replace us very
quickly
and i want them to be to be better than
we have been
thank you very much
i have about 10 minutes if anybody wants
to ask questions or anything
yes
the question is is how do people get in
touch with the local maker spaces
um and the maker movement inside their
domain
uh region city uh that sort of breakdown
if you just google search your city and
makerspace
um it'll you'll pop up something the
other
key term to look for in google is a
maker faire in your city
most cities at this point have at least
one if not
three maker faires going on and it's run
by local people just
trying to bring people together to show
off what's going on
um that's an option the beauty of uh so
let me separate those out for you
i'm gonna grab the pepsi real quick um
the maker shop or maker space
is an area where people gather to make
things a maker faire is where people
gather to show off the things that they
have made
there's another group out there called
nodebots user groups and they meet up
haphazardly and not well everywhere
that's another access point to gain
access to so that would be
sort of what i would go yeah
the question is does a node bot
fundamentally boil down to a host
driving through a serial port to a
microcontroller
and drive that that is the original
creation of nodebots pretty much square
on the head
the evolution of it since then has been
to use
wi-fi or btle or
nfc communications to cut that wire and
have
the intelligence and the compute over on
the host
go over some transport medium whether it
be serial port or wi-fi
to a microcontroller and drive it from
there
yep absolutely um and
i use javascript uh the team
out of hybrid theory or hybrid group
they have built gobot
which is similar to the nodebots
ideology but in go
and r2 which is the similar ideology in
ruby as well as also cylon which is the
similar idea
in javascript and their idea is to
create
robot ops which sits atop all the
different languages and whatever
language you want you can plug it in
to this overarching operations control
board
and be able to control a go based one
versus a ruby based one versus a
javascript based one
so that area is very much blossoming
still i have
i only like javascript because it's
accessible it doesn't necessarily mean
it's the right
necessarily the complete right and only
tool for this task
so any other questions
thank you so what are some of the
challenges in teaching
like what things have come up here okay
so that's a wonderful question the
question is is what
based off of my experience what are some
of the challenges that come up when
teaching this to kids
if i may and it's it's mainly my fault
but it's a piece of experience advice
i'm going to give to everyone
would be walking in there with the
assumption that the kids aren't
already hip to it most times when you
walk into a classroom
at least for me and i'm only using my
anecdotal evidence i make the assumption
that okay i've got to teach you the
entire world
up and i'll say so we're going to use a
3d printer and they will start going
down a path of
what about the ramifications of
copyright infringement on 3d printing
and i'm like
wait what it's because these these terms
aren't necessarily foreign to them
they are actually seeing this everywhere
and fully understanding it
it's not as guarded as it may seem
from our position so i have learned over
the time
to not go into there assuming that i
have to build from the ground up
that i have to first find out where they
sit and then
train based off of that or work based
off of that so hey
have you heard of a 3d printer oh you
have great what are your questions let's
get those off the table first because
younger people have awesome ideas and
they want to get all of them out and the
best thing to do is to first
address that clear the slate and then
move forward
the other challenges are up until
recently
costing is a problem while
developers are by and large paid
rather handsomely not all people in all
areas and all walks
are and part of that is trying to figure
out solutions whether it be through
kickstarter programs
or as we've learned doing this corporate
backing
take money from the rich and democratize
it out to everybody
bring the prices down to the children to
the schools
and make it accessible to them so that
way i don't have a budget
isn't actually a valid excuse for not
having this and these programs available
the other one is humans like it's hard
to replicate yourself and be at all
schools in a county
so that's kind of why i do two sides of
the mission go out and do it as well as
go out and try to
encourage and incite more people to go
out and do it
other than that uh not too much else
they
get it like there's there's no barrier
to entry for them they don't
have a fear they don't have an angst
against it they just dive in headfirst
i hope that answers your question um
okay good
yep
um
okay so the question is and please
correct me if i i misstate it um arduino
gives you a tremendous amount of power
that's very specific to arduino
um as you move through an abstraction
layer you lose
some of that specific power and
capability would that be
yep so uh it's how do you handle the
different capabilities that are native
to the platform
like in this one it's an arduino base so
the atmel chip is gonna have a special
set of
uh instructions that it can do that are
different and disjoint from
uh the spark one necessarily so the way
we do that is we create the abstraction
layer to both
afford a base level so handle your gpios
that in a normal sort of format and then
as part of that the adapter can present
or expose
other interfaces that allow access to it
so we don't necessarily constrain them
into and pigeonhole them into a singular
point
we just say for these generally used
pieces
try to conform to this normal set of
instructions
and some do some don't it's a little bit
of a thing but it's less
in my mind it's less about making
everything conform to an abstraction
layer
it's more providing that up into a layer
that's accessible so the concept of
do this and when done execute callback
is the key to that element and as long
as that workflow
and it could be promises if you're in
the node world
however you want to execute of go do
something let me know when done
and i will do something else as long as
it adheres to that sort of methodology
or that sort of ethos
it's considered in my mind a node bot
and
you you very adeptly called out uh
spark on that one but there's also like
hold on let me get to it
no there we go pinocchio which has the
benefit of being a mesh based network
topology
and i would be remiss to to not say
that's the coolest thing in the world
because you can do some amazing swarm
bots if we
had a spark here i do in the room i
didn't bring it because i
uh saw that the wi-fi might be shaky and
that's a problem like wi-fi isn't
necessarily stable everywhere
it's one of the benefits of a cord it's
stable but it's also one of the benefits
of a pinocchio which goes on its own
band and the abstraction layers can
handle that for you but it doesn't keep
the the program or the person doing it
away from those pieces it actually
exposes those specialness
and allows access to it to control it in
that same sort of a higher level
workflow construct
go here and then over there
so that is a great question repeated
when teaching kids is the command line a
barrier
and absolutely 110 this is actually why
chrome now has chrome serial
so we can actually use any chromebook to
program any robot
the same libraries that we built for
john e5
now run inside chrome in the javascript
browser interpreter that's in the
browser
if not that then there's things like
blocky
which allow you to create conditional
logic sets with blocks of code
and run it through there we're building
that piece up further and further
for this audience command line is sort
of a great thing and scripts are sort of
a great thing
which is great and eventually as they
start doing you know either rebels in
the browser or rebels in a command line
start saving those and running them and
now you start running programs and you
start building up a mentality
a mental model of how programming in the
large works
question is is there a reason why
arduino is a better starting point for
getting into these things than
uh a raspberry pi or a similar sort of
uh
chipset in my opinion they're
the biggest one is that the arduino does
one thing and does it well
it doesn't necessarily mean that the
raspberry pi or the spark or the
pinocchio or the
beaglebone any of those
aren't capable and aren't already pulled
in to this
uh you could start writing if you have a
raspberry pi but not an arduino
you can write johnny five and it'll
control the raspberry pi without a
problem
and then if you go buy an arduino you
just swap out and you're good to go and
all the code still runs and the hardware
still executes exactly the same
which is really cool that's the power of
it there's a price point difference
arduinos are much cheaper since the
design is open source
you can get it at like eight dollars for
a full board
for better for worse whereas a raspberry
pi is still
not always readily available they still
have shortages
based off of stock most of that's been
cleared up
the other thing is is that the
onboarding process for raspberry pi
includes getting an sd card
loading raspbian putting the sd card in
getting it to boot up
now set it up to a monitor and and
there's so much workflow and
infrastructure just to get
the zero point the hello world the
blinky light whereas in arduino it's
just
okay put this in and and whoo done um
your time to
awesome as i like to call it is about a
minute
with arduino full all in is about a
minute max
the time to awesome in a raspberry pi is
about 20 minutes
that's a can be a gating factor for
people getting on board it is a lot more
propensity for
frustration in that 20 minute window
than there is on the one minute window
yes
so the question is is that's great chris
but
after step zero what about the rest of
the world uh you want to build stuff
with wi-fi and stuff of that nature
i would address that or respond to that
with you're absolutely right
i would not necessarily go down the path
of raspberry pi for that
raspberry pi is going to be much better
if you want to keep the host localized
to the hardware controls
something like spark or pinocchio or
even beaglebone
black is going to be better for the
wi-fi and each of these
as mentioned earlier have fantastic
special things they do well
the new edison out of intel haven't had
access to it yet but
rick has and he said it's fantastic
there's a great bridge point there with
the wi-fi
they each have their own special story
this is the thing about the internet of
things is it's still very new
and each one of the players here and
beyond
focus on one thing and doing it
tremendously well
and because of that they also have one
thing that they don't do
really really well if you want to do
something with battery life
you're not going to use a spark they
have not cared about their
power consumption use yet they will over
time but as of right now they're so if
you're going to put something
like a garage door opener that you're
going to control via wi-fi
spark assuming you don't have a main
power line coming in
spark on a 9-volt battery is going to
run down pretty quickly whereas
imp is tuned for power consumption and
can be
very delicately controlled to just sip
little bits of power as needed
the pinocchio is great if you're in an
area that doesn't have wi-fi
and or has shaky wi-fi like a conference
setting
they each have their own little perfect
things someday though one will have all
of them but for right now each one has
their own
so what i would say is absolutely right
we generally use arduinos is just the
gateway the start point here's what you
can do now we have access to this board
don't change your code plunk it in look
no more wires
hooray move on to the next task and then
that way
the beauty of it is is that same
knowledge the same workflow the same
programming works
on all of them so
yeah this will have to be the last
question i think i'm already over but
the question is is kids and soldering
irons um
a funny story quick anecdotal funny
story we do a event called robots conf
where we
bring 200 some odd engineer developers
uh of all different languages together
and we're pitching it to the hotel and
we're like so we're going to set up nine
to 10 soldering stations and then
needles get up to like 450
600 degrees are you cool with that
they're like wait what um
this is before we told them they were
gonna have laser cutters in the room and
uh so that's a concern not just yep not
just for
kids but also adults uh hexy here is
entirely screw based
and plug-ins so you get uh we can talk
about this later
let me get off the stage so that way the
next one can get up thank you all
very much please go build robots